on these platforms we've seen a complete
rise of what I'll call kind of a new
generation of creators right and you've
tweeted quite a bit about this what I
was called the Creator class right so a
number of tweets that you've had
I just love where you're like look you
know Joe Rogan's a billionaire Kylie's a
billionaire and the this creator class
is some we'll call it new media some
will call it kind of influence or the
influencer economy but but it's
definitely something that wasn't there
in the size scope or mechanism that it
is today even ten years ago right and so
maybe talk a little bit about like what
is drawing your attention to that and
how do you view that creator class kind
of in the world order if you will of
what we're seeing happen yeah so I
started going down to LA in like 2008 I
had sgm so she gave me no it was one of
the first gaming companies social gaming
companies on Facebook platform and then
on the iPhone and you know on the iPhone
where one in four iphones had one of our
games and we merged that company with a
company called mind joltin that's jam
city now so they're doing it like half a
billion on the I mean revenue on the
iPhone now and so I was going on LA and
I was meeting with people in that world
in the entertainment world and I
remember like back then and was saying
like hey bring loss to the Facebook
platform as a social game and you know
it was hard to convince people to take
those kinds of bets right because of
that same conservative type thinking
about platforms and taking that kind of
risk but it was absolutely the right
call to do right
you know same same pitch on the iPhone
and so on and then when I started
investing I I started talking to friends
of mine down there
having these discussions and I was
trying to build bridges between Silicon
Valley and in LA and some people got in
some people were like I want 20% of the
company and I was like sorry like that's
not gonna happen that's not how it works
you got to put some money into it you
got you know invest just like everybody
else and help the company you know
you're not getting 20% and so the we
help change the culture down there to an
investor class culture right - you know
shareholder culture versus like I'm me
and I I deserve 20% so that was
important so you know conversations and
meeting people like you know Jay Brown
and jay-z or Troy Carter or Scooter
Braun or you know Adam Lieber and Ari
Emanuel and bringing them into BRR like
those were the ones that were that got
it invested and made a great return on
their investment with with us into Oh
BRR right and helped the company a lot
and and all of that but then I think the
legend of those investments is what
changed the culture in LA because the
people who passed that I talked to but I
won't name right but they they they were
kicking themselves they're like what was
I thinking why didn't I put in that
$250,000 check and get a foreigner next
return whatever and you know ended up
being so it's um that's one then between
2008 and now and 2020 the the evolution
that's happened is that people now the
influencer and the founders and the
people have are the brands are the
company and you know companies can live
and die but an influential person
wherever it's a founder and an
entertainer and so on anyone that has an
audience that's loyal and spends time
with them similar to how you you do
rogon does and others do you know have a
chance to build something that impacts
billions of people and makes them
billionaires right and so the power
especially in terms of the new media
paradigm is that you know these
influence or influencers who are also
great entrepreneurs can build incredible
value for themselves their families
their employees their teams and so on
and investors faster than in any other
time in history what's driving that is
that a technology inflection point is
that a just mindset people now are
thinking there's a different way to
monetize this or build these companies
or is there something else that's
driving it
what's the death of the middlemen just
like the death of the salesman
the middleman was a remnant of a
different world and all of the people
they were in between these influencers
and the audience and not just people but
companies all of the agencies and the
management companies and all these other
things that were in the middle taking a
cut even the lawyers in LA get a cut of
everything someone makes it's insanity
it's you know a form of slavery and so
you know I'm not gonna get a lot of love
from the lawyers in LA but I mean it
does make when I found out the lawyers
get a percentage like you know agents
are managed and it was like why pay
their fees and move on but that was the
mentality and the culture which then in
turn made people desperate and
overestimating their worth and saying I
want 20% of the company when it's like
no no invest make a great amazing return
and learn how to be a founder and build
your own company so I think it's that
collapse and compression where the
influencer and the audience became one
right like it's that trend that we just
saw where the young lady
created a cults right you know the
step-step chickens or whatever it's gone
I think that's hilarious right but it's
a genius move because she realized that
if she could collapse the audience and
she becomes the audience and the
audience becomes her and suddenly she's
a platform and suddenly the audience and
the fans are a platform in unison right
United and look what they did
overnight top of the charts you know you
know put out an app the ranking goes up
all the comments streams of all these
points are suddenly same profile picture
genius what it reminds me a lot of is
the old model was let's build a product
or a service and then go spend a bunch
of time money and resources to find the
customers or the audience right so it's
kind of company first audience and
customers second now though that's
inverting right actually what's
happening is people are building the
audience's first and then they're
basically going back to the drawing
boards okay I've got this massive
audience of hundreds of thousands or
millions of people what do I build to
serve them
is it a mobile app is it a you know a
merchandise store is it some other
product I mean look at Kylie Jenner or
whatever and to me that almost feels
like if you can build the audience it's
actually a great way to de-risk the
company building right because you know
that there's an audience there and so
you're drastically increasing the
probability of the product market fit in
the future the product market fit is the
is the person the brand is the person
and and let me talk about reducing cap
right the customer acquisition costs if
if you if you have an audience and you
can do what Joe did and went and what
Daniel act just there together
you know that's the beginning of the end
of any kind of middlemen in the media
world and we already have experienced
that in the tech world where the Elon
Xin chào
this can create you know incredible
world-changing companies on their own
and then back others like them all right
or the that Kylie can create a billion
dollar company and she's what 22 23
years old or Kanye can take his genius
and design a shoe and easy and create a
three billion plus company with his
creativity alright and so I think you
know that's that's the trend it's not
it's not going away it's here and I
think you know this this new wrinkle
what would it kind of inspired me around
thinking through is ephemeral
influencers right like you know she
might suddenly show up with you know a
cult right and suddenly have a million
people following and being there the
platform and it might go away and that's
okay you know so it made me think of
kind of like the Andy Warhol quote of
everyone's gonna have 15 minutes of fame
right I think it's in this case
everyone's gonna have 15 million dollars
right it's look like she might make
fifteen million dollars right and that's
a life-changing amount for her and her
family but because she was creative
about something and she basically
created a new form factor within other
platforms a platform within a platform
and it might be ephemeral and go away
and that's okay